is she pregnant
that's why he slapped the [ __ ] out
I ain't buying
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm precious I'm Frank
we decided to open our relationship
about three to four years ago yeah it
was uh tricky at the time we had
different ideas of what a open
relationship was right so I kind of just
want a friend that we could like be more
than friends I guess both of you what is
the best outcome of this experience
today I think it's going back to our
hotel that's around now just
a date with
it's going to date with someone I mean I
thought Robert
I'll let you guys know he's not playing
no he's not playing there's no there's
not one ounce he's trying to [ __ ] left
right and Center yeah and she's trying
to bring a third person in that's not
what I'm afraid that we can both get to
know exactly man I'm trying to [ __ ]
[ __ ] on the side let's go get in my
way talk about get to know these
told me she would just go wait at home
in her [ __ ] apron and some buns out
you feel me what was she looking for she
looking for another girl is she looking
for a guy to get like yo sit in the
corner
[ __ ]
is that what you looking for on the side
yeah here and you're not touch me Mama
again ravage and she wants to get
ravaged by another dude I don't know
good for her
all right
hi
I'm precious Jasmine nice beautiful
[Music]
hi Tulane Jasmine Precious
Precious
hi Jordan
hi hi bye
hi hi bye
w
[Music]
by the precious hi no precious bye
precious hi precious bye precious hey
precious bye precious hey precious don't
get it Precious
Precious go get it Precious Precious
precious
girl you thought you was precious but
you ain't so you gotta go by money hurry
hurry now you know you not really
precious
anyways that's actually pretty good yeah
that was pretty good yeah that's pretty
good even though you know yeah pretty
good your beatboxing was better than my
my bars I appreciate you it's fine thank
you thank you for being with canvas I
could paint on it's fine even though the
paintings doo doo they can't do it
you know what I think the painting was
precious you feel me yeah yeah it's okay
you got other bars it's fine
I don't think
hiking
they're not gonna lie these women are
busted
I was thinking bro
[Music]
you slapped her I don't care what you
say I don't care what you think get what
you say he slapped her you can bring
that [ __ ] back blacked up big t-shirt
Billy eilish bring that [ __ ] back what
is she pregnant
that's why he slapped the [ __ ] out
pleasure
wait wait
ask him by the first the first time the
first time I saw that [ __ ] and I was
like nah I decided to not see it
and he slapped her that's why he slapped
he she he slapped your kids
he's paying that [ __ ] before
that [ __ ] was out her nah her
nah they definitely not
this [ __ ] out of contest is about Hey
listen listen I'm down for threesomes
not forces here imagine this [ __ ] this
[ __ ] coming out like this
out her belly you the [ __ ] that was
bumping my head what's up Dad oh it
ain't you yo you don't be crazy if she
probably was like [ __ ] why'd my baby
mama show up [ __ ] get out of here I
already said no why are you following me
dude that's all the dudes out here
having sex with pregnant women who
aren't their girls their wives as weird
as [ __ ] to me I'm not trying to be
stigmatized to nobody
but there's something really weird about
me pumping a girl full of something and
there's something kicking me back like
[ __ ] it's crowded in here already like
I don't know that's just weird to me you
know what I'm saying sometimes I try not
[ __ ] this [ __ ] but sometimes you kicking
me back me back I'm not going to give
you that one it's time for us to
pontificate okay let's pontificate
let's say she pregnant okay let's say
she pregnant and let's say
both of them are pro-life but they're
about to [ __ ] meaning they say
this is It's a baby at conception like
once it's in the womb it's a baby it's
not it's not something you're trying to
feed it yeah it's a human life deserving
protection I know where you're going
they did it in kids
ain't that [ __ ] illegal
excuse me
wow we understood [ __ ] he didn't have
to pray just think about it [ __ ] now you
got like [ __ ] with images in
their head yeah I just want you guys
watching at home if you guys do this
[ __ ] in your pro-life you're dealing
kids see always focus on the negative no
no no no no
the positive is I'm trying to keep them
out of jail no no that's something you
go to jail man that's something no no
that's not negative
[Music]
and
[Music]
um
because the girl passes no white woman
no I'm with that she said because you
see the way he reluctantly did yeah
sorry my girl's not gonna like you
hold up let's see if he accepts her I
don't think he's gonna accept her either
[Music]
you're pretty
[Music]
cute very beautiful oh you got some huge
cities pigs yeah you got some tickle
Bitties you look like you could be my
milk this [ __ ] said yeah
it's got something I could lick
underneath you feel me that's when you
know she got big knockers when you can
lift them [ __ ] over put over your
head and go
more than that acts like an air Muffler
but you can also look God damn bro the
under TV where there's a lot of real
estate that's some [ __ ] right there
what nothing you ain't never been no big
old titties
if you feel really strongly that they
should be here so you guys get one save
to agree upon the anime girl she had
really curly hair
bring her back okay
[Music]
hello
hello how are you hello Jasmine precious
nice to meet you Jasmine nice to meet
you okay
I'm gonna assume that's pretty mean what
but I really believe
I noticed that the people who are into
like open relationships with polyamory
and all this other stuff are like
generally pretty ugly
physically speaking
I have no data like sometimes you go to
like these parties or like these BSM
stuff and like a lot of people present
are nasty looking
carry on am I wrong I don't know well
that's your department you have a whole
podcast where you celebrate these people
I'm going to [ __ ] parties you don't
go there and celebrate the person you
look
like I mean I've been once
full-time uh
what's up oh they're ugly looking okay
hold up but you also interview them so
what are they all attracted to the ones
you interview yeah I've seen some pretty
attractive one that's you better answer
that they wasn't right now that doesn't
matter I don't I don't care
all this to say it's just something I
noticed from like the polyamorous World
it seems like the people were really
into it and like advocated for it all
this whole the people I never want to be
in a polyamorous hey I think it worked
for me
um but maybe I'm wrong maybe you guys in
the comments feel differently you know
what I'm saying I just noticed every
time I look at these people I notice a
lot of septum rings I noticed shaved
side heads I know there's a lot of
colorful hair
still intact you know what I'm saying
like it's just little things you notice
I could be wrong I'm a pretty average
dude myself so I fit in that box damn
yeah
how did you feel about me swiping no and
then us bringing you back
yo
I've never done it before I've been like
in your guys position I've been the in
the couple getting the girl but I've
never been like the girl like with the
couple oh this is an open relationship
but no [ __ ] allowed
it depends everybody got their rules
most of them are saying no [ __ ]
allowed
um I wouldn't say that yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah tell us about your experience
that's not mine I haven't done that but
most of the dudes who say they're open
to open relationships even when they
come to the girls like you can invite
another girl you can't be bringing in
another dude because guys view it
differently guys see another dude rolls
a bedroom they're like oh we gonna
devour this person like she a piece of
meat and and you do that with your
homies on a [ __ ] you don't like
um if that's your girl that's the woman
that you actually you're not here for
you're not you're not trying to turn
into a bang Bros video it's you know to
be like describe
that polyamorous relationship that's a
train
yeah yeah it's going two two Full Speed
Ahead you feel me no I'm not saying it's
all right I'm just tell you what it is
yeah me personally if I was to advocate
for all relationship I'd be fair and do
it on both sides if I was to buy wood
into it but if I was I'm talking about
because I've had a girl test me on that
[ __ ] sometime
and I'm like yeah you know I mean open
relationships are dope you know what I
mean just throwing that out there right
she was like yeah yeah the word I'm like
yeah she's like so you don't mind if I
bring another dude I was like yeah yeah
I'll leave give you guys some chicken
come back two hours later
he's like no that's disgusting I'm like
gotcha [ __ ]
gotcha
you thought I was gonna swear no Full
Speed Ahead let's see who turns first
and she did
guys gotcha [ __ ] gotcha you thought you
was gonna play me
go ahead get appendix I know you don't
actually want him yeah see you're just
talking wow yeah sometimes you gotta
call me Bluff yeah you gotta put a
condom on the table let me say like
y'all go have some fun I'm gonna go
watch a movie get some popcorn maybe
save for another and I'll be back a
little bit later hey you got my number
and I need you to clean the bedroom
because me and Cindy gonna be [ __ ] in
there okay let's go
gotcha [ __ ]
women think that's such a gotcha women
actually think like yeah you don't mind
if I bring another dude because dude's
like
play call their Bluff
bring another Beach color Bluff bring
another Moon [ __ ] and now that
I'm single like I kind of want to
experiment and be more open-minded and
see what I really like so I have a
partner um we've been together for eight
years and we're open I think that normal
like normal dating like has I don't know
I haven't really felt like I've hit a
stride here so I think that like I'm the
kind of person like I'll try anything
once so I'm more of the merrier you know
I like doing everything I guess I just I
just like doing what the world has to
offer oh this girl is dead inside
poor thing what happened to you yeah I
feel bad for what happened I yeah I feel
bad it's not even out whoa I like some
[ __ ] happened I you know what I mean you
you sorry you get so she got some shots
that's a lot shout outs to her nice so
what do you do for a living the main
goal is I want to be like a school
psychologist for foster kids yeah I'm
really excited to be almost done
foster kids with the women you have an
open relationship with and she also is a
cycle I don't see how you saw the appeal
in that yeah that's really weird but
shout out to them for being foster
parents
oh my God I'm a comedian you gotta do a
joke come on oh my gosh have you ever
seen those like guys born after 2000 who
wear those like shirts that say Reagan
Bush 84. when I went to college I
definitely saw a lot of them and I was
like okay I don't think you know
anything about what 84 was like yeah I
think you just want a virtue signal like
hey I just I hate Poirier people and I
think I think that we should treat those
guys who wear those shirts the same way
that we treat like 16 year old girls who
wear AC DC shirts so like bruh whenever
Hassan fans try to do stated but makes
me cringe so [ __ ] hard
abilities not because you go to Open Mic
so you're a comedian
and it's okay
you trying you're learning so I support
it hopefully you get good
YouTube is out the place to try out that
joke
because that's set up punchline was
non-existent
you know those guys that were like going
after the 2000s like they're with those
Reagan Bush shirts like so I was going
to University at one time and I saw one
of those guys wearing this shirt and
like I said hey Obama did it better and
he was like
shut your bush up
and that was a better joke and that was
a better joke
the thing is I whenever you thought
whenever you say to someone hey
um oh [ __ ] you're someone that tells you
hey you're you're a comedian do a joke
your answer should be no
no we're not doing that what do you do
for a living you work in a bank open a
bank account it's not the time and place
right same thing look what a lot of
people ask me what I do I say I'm a
singer and they're like sing for me like
Yay girl
girl tell me fellas have you seen her it
must have been five minutes ago good yay
thank you
girl yeah yeah I get my little crisp
Breezy on I don't beat these women but I
do everything okay I was like whiskey
nah you know yeah split US 20 was 19.
girl
yay girl I always like the beginning
yeah yeah that's all I like I think it's
really hard for one person to expect one
person to like fulfill everything you
want everything you need and that's like
a lot of pressure but when you have like
multiple people you know people feel
different roles in your life for
different things so it's just easier to
like get what people have to offer yeah
yeah yeah my wife's cool but Cindy does
anal so yeah I need different things
from different people
foreign
butt stuff for her I go hiking with my
wife and with Cindy I go hiking up her
butthole
[Laughter]
that's what it looks like when it's
lubed up he's like there's a breeze in
the power yeah you could park a whole
Cliff bar in there
it might come out a little extra Brown
let's carry on hey it's already Brown it
goes in right what can Brown do for you
that's UPS I got a package yeah should I
go in the back door yeah all right all
right enough butt stuff
all right we have to come down to
something we have to do the process of
elimination I thought you were gonna say
all of them
but we pick
[Music]
Ed
up
lovely to meet you thank you so much bye
ladies hi nice meeting you